we're gonna head to Japan where Angelina
Jolie reunited with her college son
Maddox that look of pride pretty much
says it all Maddox traveled just over
700 miles from Seoul to Tokyo for the
epic mother-son reunion at the
Maleficent two premiere et has learned
the trip was their first time seeing
each other since Angelina dropped him
off at University in August in Jelena
travelled to Tokyo with 14 year old
daughter Sahara who is looking all
grown-up and turning into a little
fashionista we can't get enough of their
matching halter neckline and the fact
that Angelina stepped out of her black
gown comfort zone she literally shook
things up in a Ralph and Russo dress
with a glass bead fringe earlier this
week Angelina marveled at her Elvis
daughter's growth at the LA premiere she
looked gorgeous that dress Hannah was
beautiful that night she walked the
carpet with five of her kids and now we
know their behind-the-scenes secret to
making it look so effortless Disney
cameras captured the massive command
center of style that took over two rooms
plus the driveway in her sprawling
estate the yard massive the pets
plentiful there was a lizard rabbit and
a dog just hanging out amongst the
organized chaos you know moms everywhere
are saying how the heck does she do that
make it look so easy wrangling them all
and happy they wrangle me honestly
they're they're more together as the
[ __ ] is the most organized in the
family
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]